ja ich war da mal wieder unterwegs auf
tik tok ist eine ganz neue app ist das
also was ist mit dir passiert der macher
buch hat mich entführt er ist der macher
buch hat der macher bruder macht dann
macht das aufschlag auf und zu
[Musik]
haben wir hier auch was witziges
ist das eine brille wenn du liegst dass
du quasi du guckst nach oben aber in der
britischen spiegel du gibst nach vorne
wo polen verlegt und weil einem solchen
ort eine fette freundin tragen du keine
ruhe wichtig ich will dich nicht mit
und es gibt ja auch kein haus du bist 18
nach weniger zeit einmal fassungslos mit
meinem humor
diese
[Musik]
ist das kind
die scheiße vom hund gefahren ja das
lief dann ziemlich beschissen
[Musik]
ich hab mal ein boxsack und genau wie
willst du dann sagen wir es einsetzen
hat das ihr da verstanden welche fragen
man keine fragen wir das bin ich hier
mit der unterricht läuft das wirklich so
ab dass genau wie früher im unterricht
wenn irgendwer sich auch gemeldet hat
und du dich auch und der andere sagt
dann so die lösung und es ist so
komplett nicht das was du sagen wollte
ist aber danach nimmt der lehrer dichter
und sagte ja ich wollte dass ich bald
dass all das wollte ich auch sagen
katzen mit den leuten ist aber heute
eine
es ist der sohn
wie findet reisters
ich will da überhaupt nicht einen
schneemann kritisieren aber irgendwie
steht er halt so
er hat aber tatsächlich ein paar tage
später noch einen schneemann gebaut
guck mal ist aber meiner ist niemand
hier verbessern
es ist eher so kuck mal ist aber dass
verbessern
das hier ist er also ein vertrau mir ist
niemand zu bauen bis nummer eins
punkt 1
die kamera ist meistens viel besser und
ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen dass das
dann war es aber man könnte das in
betracht ziehen
diese ganzen samsung nutzer die maus
ganz komische images allen irgendwie
sowas oder so oder so da er wem er wem's
gefällt
das ist ein mix aus einer toten taube
und dem teufel oder was war das so ab
heute gibt es mit gesunder ernährung bei
mir gut mit ernährung habe gestern hatte
man in factory selfmade chores gemacht
geschmeckt wie meinen fuß
jakob buck internet-branche ich glaube
das ist ein tornado diese leute die
sagen ich habe es gesagt schön
glückwunsch taz gesagt also sind rasiert
aber kein ende
langeweile denn obwohl er so war alter
gibt es nicht so wenn auch nicht geben
sonst gefragt wie du bist doch vorher
wird echt jetzt etwas passiert hier so
viele menschen habe ich moderator sein
sollst du nein nicht jeder kamerad vor
sein
das ist bisher alles einfach war mein
gott dieses lied dicker ich kann es
nicht mehr hören
krass ich wusste gar nicht dass es
andere auch als siegel gibt
seid ihr auch einer von denen die gesagt
haben jetzt die niemals tickt doch
runterladen werden und jetzt süchtig
danach sind und hier morgens immer noch
nicht schlafen ja genau und deshalb will
ich ja der stelle mein heutiges video
als auch beendet meine lieben freunde
wichtig dass schuster heute gefallen hat
und das gern einen daumen hoch unter
media wurden jetzt mein kanalfest auch
keinen zeitdruck seid und wir sehen uns
morgen einem neuen video wieder wenn es
wieder heißt
[Musik]